the Harvey Weinstein scandal was front
and center at Friday's convention of
women activists in Detroit at the event
actress Rose McGowan spoke publicly for
the first time since accusing Harvey
Weinstein of rape of the more than fifty
alleged victims McGowan was among the
first prominent actresses to speak out
following the explosive New York Times
expose on Weinstein's behavior
here's Adriana Diaz I have been silence
for twenty years I have been [ __ ] shamed
and you know what I'm just like you
actress Rose McGowan addressed the
opening session of the women's
convention in Detroit a scarlet letter
is theirs
it is not ours the convention grew out
of the women's march on Washington in
January organizers say they're bolstered
by the wave of women stepping forward
since the New York Times reported over
three weeks ago that Harvey Weinstein
routinely assaulted women including
McGowan it will not stand
in 1997 Weinstein reportedly paid
McGowan $100,000 in a settlement for an
incident in a hotel room Weinstein
denies all accusations of non-consensual
sex they had their foot on our necks for
a very long time it's time to return the
favor
McGowan appeared on a panel dedicated to
helping survivors of sexual assault even
just with Harvey Weinstein is like the
linchpin pulled out of the grenade and
we're about to see the grenade also
speaking out was actress Amber Tamblyn
who says she was sexually assaulted by
an ex how pervasive is this problem in
Hollywood it's pretty pervasive and to
be honest you know there's been a lot of
there's been a lot of criticism of of
people saying oh they all knew and it's
really not true our business is cyclical
and protective those things accumulate
and they sort of create an environment
in which everything sort of sounds like
hearsay Tamblyn says she hopes the
movement against abuse resonates beyond
Hollywood it's time for everybody to
start speaking out and to talk about
also the policies that are being placed
on women
and for us to have ownership over our
own bodies our own rights our own
education everything for CBS this
morning Saturday Adriana Diaz Detroit
you know seismic thing we are witnessing
right now Anthony you look at those
pictures of all of the accusers that
have come forward and the Harvey
Weinstein case and it is it is shocking
and it is stunning and it continues yeah
there are more that came out last night
in it and a new New Yorker piece that's
been posted Anabella skewer the actress
says she was raped by Harvey Weinstein
Daryl Hannah says she was assaulted you
know so this just continues and of as
we've seen it it's now having
repercussions out beyond in other
Indians well yes it is
cataclysmic chain of events